Trascrizione: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buonasera a tutti.
La domanda di questa sera
è magari, apparentemente,
scollegata dalla bellezza;
ma vedrete che non sarà così.
Perché investire nello spazio?
È una domanda che ha
perfettamente senso, in realtà,
assolutamente legittima,
perché le priorità che affliggono
il nostro pianeta
sono enormemente,
apparentemente, più importanti.
Che senso ha investire denaro,
tempo, risorse, forze,
per mandare magari una sonda in orbita
attorno a un pianeta
o per avere la prima
immagine del buco nero,
o per studiare delle rocce marziane?
Non solo.
Pensate che, nel 1977,
la NASA lanciò due sonde gemelle,
chiamate Voyager,
per studiare il sistema solare esterno.
A bordo di queste due sonde
c'erano due dischi d'oro,
due dischi completamente ricoperti d'oro.
Due oggetti che erano
apparentemente inutili,
senza alcuna utilità
da un punto di vista scientifico.
Nonostante questo vennero spesi soldi,
vennero investite risorse umane
per mettere due oggetti così
su due navicelle che avrebbero
vagato tra le stelle.
Qual è il senso di tutto questo?
Ecco: io, questa sera,
vorrò darvi due risposte:
una risposta pratica,
che magari soddisferà molte delle persone
che si chiedono, si fanno
giustamente la domanda iniziale.
Però non sarà la risposta
che voglio darvi io,
perché in realtà io nemmeno
vorrò darvela, una risposta.
Quello che vorrò fare, questa sera
sarà un viaggio, fatto di sogni,
di bellezza, di consapevolezza,
al termine del quale, magari,
la risposta la troverete dentro di voi.
E per cominciare,
parlerò di un fallimento.
Di uno di quelli che avrebbe potuto essere
uno dei più grandi insuccessi
dell'esplorazione spaziale.
Nel 1990, gli scienziati
mandarono in orbita attorno alla terra
un telescopio spaziale,
a cui diedero il nome di Hubble,
uno strumento che avrebbe dovuto
cambiare completamente
la nostra comprensione del cosmo.
Eppure, un paio di settimane
dopo il lancio,
questa che vedete a sinistra
è una delle immagini
che cominciarono ad arrivare:
completamente sfocata,
totalmente inutilizzabile.
E questo per un minuscolo difetto
dello specchio principale del telescopio.
Dopo 30 anni, sappiamo
che il telescopio spaziale Hubble è stato
ed è tuttora un successo clamoroso;
e questo perché tre anni dopo il lancio
andarono fisicamente gli astronauti
a correggere questo difetto,
dopodiché iniziò a mandare immagini
come quella che vedete a destra,
finalmente all'altezza delle attese.
Eh, però ragazzi,
tre anni di dati persi su un progetto così
sarebbe stato un disastro pazzesco!
Ecco quindi che gli astronomi
iniziarono a sviluppare delle tecniche
capaci di migliorare la gamma dinamica,
la risoluzione e il dettaglio
delle immagini sfocate
che Hubble stava mandando,
producendo finalmente risultati
che non erano perfetti
ma utilizzabili
dalla comunità scientifica.
La cosa meravigliosa è che queste tecniche
vennero prestate alla medicina,
producendo risultati come questo.
Questa è un'immagine mammografica
ottenuta con quelle tecniche.
I medici riuscirono a individuare
microcalcificazioni nel seno
molto più piccole,
che prima sarebbero risultate invisibili,
potendo così fare diagnosi più precoci
e attuare trattamenti migliori
e molto meno invasivi.
Ecco, pensate:
se questo risultato proviene
da un insuccesso della ricerca spaziale,
salvando vite umane,
riuscite ad immaginare la quantità immensa
di ricadute tecnologiche
sulla vita di noi esseri umani
qua sulla terra,
con gli infiniti successi
che l'esplorazione spaziale
ha prodotto negli ultimi decenni?
Immaginate per esempio
i filtri per l'acqua,
che restituiscono il bene più prezioso
a popolazioni che altrimenti
potrebbero morire di sete;
le tecnologie che usiamo tutti i giorni:
quella che avete nei vostri cellulari,
internet, il GPS o le previsioni meteo,
che vi permettono di sapere
se domani dovete prendere l'ombrello,
una volta alzati, oppure no;
tutti i satelliti che monitorano
costantemente il nostro pianeta,
e che ci hanno permesso di capire
che i cambiamenti climatici sono
una nostra principale responsabilità.
Ma è la stessa ricerca spaziale
a fornici quelle tecnologie,
come i pannelli solari,
che ci stanno fornendo un minimo aiuto
per contrastare le conseguenze
di questi cambiamenti climatici.
Ecco: la ricerca spaziale
si traduce in progresso,
in tecnologie democraticamente
a disposizione di tutta l'umanità.
Quale risposta pratica c'è,
migliore di questa,
a molte delle persone che si pongono
la domanda iniziale?
Però, in realtà, non è per queste cose
che noi alziamo gli occhi al cielo;
non è per avere questo
che noi esploriamo il cosmo.
Pensateci:
nessuno si chiede il senso
dell'arte, della filosofia,
della musica, della danza,
di tutte le arti.
Però, effettivamente,
non ci danno un ritorno tecnologico,
non risolvono problemi.
Ma forse nessuno si chiede
il senso di tutte queste cose
perché sono una espressione
dei nostri sentimenti
e delle nostre emozioni;
e che senso avrebbe chiedersi
qual è il motivo
per cui gli esseri umani esternano
ciò che sentono dentro?
Non avrebbe alcun senso.
Questo perché esprimere
le nostre emozioni, i nostri sentimenti
è ciò che ci rende vivi,
è ciò che letteralmente
ci rende esseri umani.
Tra le cose che l'arte
ci ha lasciato in eredità
è sapere da dove veniamo,
sapere chi eravamo,
fin da quando l'arte era utilizzata
come fondamentale mezzo di comunicazione.
Ma non solo:
perché l'arte ci fa capire chi siamo stati
utilizzando il linguaggio
della bellezza delle forme,
della scrittura, dei colori,
e delle geometrie.
L'arte è anche quella cosa
che racconta le nostre battaglie,
l'arte è rivoluzione
fatta con un pennello,
con uno scalpello, con una penna;
e perché no, pure con la nostra voce.
Tutte cose che hanno colpito
gli animi e il cuore delle persone
molto più di tutte le spade,
di tutti i fucili e di tutte le pistole
che abbiamo mai potuto creare.
E che cos'è l'esplorazione dello spazio,
se non la comprensione della forma
più alta e sublime di arte?
Arte che non abbiamo creato noi,
ma che è la natura stessa
ad averci regalato
e che noi dobbiamo semplicemente
limitarci a comprendere!
Fin da quando eravamo degli ominidi
che accendevano il fuoco
all'interno delle grotte,
siamo stati abituati
ad alzare lo sguardo al cielo,
ad usarlo come guida per orientarci,
per capire dove andare,
per scandire lo scorrere del tempo.
Fin da quando abbiamo messo piede
su questo pianeta,
abbiamo capito che osservare il cielo
era nel nostro animo
di incredibili esploratori.
Ed è proprio grazie ai nostri tentativi
di comprendere il cielo
che abbiamo fatto alcune
delle rivoluzioni più straordinarie
non solo della scienza,
ma dell'intera umanità.
Quando Galileo osservò le fasi di Venere,
abbiamo scoperto che non eravamo noi
il centro dell'universo;
quando un astronomo di nome Hubble,
all'inizio del secolo scorso,
aveva osservato
una piccola stella variabile
all'interno della galassia di Andromeda,
abbiamo capito che l'universo
non era nemmeno limitato
alla nostra galassia,
ma era molto ma molto più grande.
Ed è quando abbiamo iniziato
a costruire i più potenti telescopi,
che ci è risultato chiaro
che la nostra galassia,
il nostro posto nel cosmo,
non aveva nulla di speciale:
la nostra galassia era una
delle migliaia di miliardi
che popolano l'universo.
E noi abbiamo capito il nostro posto
nel cosmo, nel nostro universo
studiando lo spazio qui da terra;
ma è facendo il processo inverso,
andando nello spazio
e studiando da lì il nostro pianeta,
che abbiamo capito qual era
il nostro posto in questo mondo,
e qual era il nostro ruolo.
Da lassù la terra è piccola, sospesa
nel buio freddo e inospitale del cosmo;
da lassù, la terra appare
incredibilmente fragile,
con la sua esile atmosfera
che permette a noi esseri umani
di sopravvivere sulla sua superficie.
Però, nonostante
questa sua immensa fragilità,
è proprio da lassù che abbiamo capito
che la Terra è un posto bellissimo,
che non ha né barriere e né confini,
è la nostra casa ed è l'unica casa
che abbiamo mai avuto e che mai avremo,
e la dobbiamo preservare tutti insieme
come un'unica specie.
Immagini come questa
- immagino l'abbiate riconosciuta,
è dello sbarco dell'uomo sulla luna -
alla fine sono molto simili
alle pitture rupestri che vi ho mostrato
e che abbiamo lasciato nelle grotte
migliaia di anni fa,
nonostante l'immensa distanza temporale,
tecnologica che le separa,
perché immagini così ci fanno capire
chi eravamo, da dove siamo venuti
e dove vogliamo andare.
Immagini così sono di una bellezza,
di una potenza disarmante.
Raccontano la nostra forza,
raccontano la nostra tenacia,
la nostra perseveranza,
la nostra capacità,
il fatto che quando vogliamo
sappiamo cooperare in direzione
di un obiettivo comune.
Immagini come questa, secondo me,
sono la forma più sublime di arte,
arte in questo caso fatta,
letteralmente, con i piedi.
Immagini così sono il simbolo
della nostra volontà di oltrepassare
i limiti che la natura ci ha imposto.
L'esplorazione spaziale, però,
non è solo la necessità umana
di oltrepassare questi limiti;
l'esplorazione spaziale è anche,
o forse soprattutto,
il desiderio dell'uomo
di sopravvivere al proprio tempo.
E questo sentimento disperato,
e meraviglioso, dell'essere umano
è proprio incarnato da quelle due sonde
di cui parlavo all'inizio,
le sonde Voyager.
Però, perché mettere due dischi d'oro
su queste due sonde?
Questo mica lo spiega.
Perché mettere due oggetti inutili
dal punto di vista scientifico
su due navicelle
che stanno vagando per il Cosmo?
Qual è il senso di questa cosa?
Perché spendere soldi, investire risorse
per un affare del genere?
Il valore di questi due dischi
non risiede nel loro materiale:
risiede nel messaggio in essi contenuto.
È un messaggio indirizzato
verso una ipotetica civiltà aliena
a cui potrebbe andare incontro
una delle due sonde.
È un messaggio che è una nostra eredità,
un frammento dei nostri sentimenti,
dei nostri pensieri
e delle nostre emozioni.
Se questa ipotetica civiltà aliena
fosse in grado di decifrare
il contenuto di questi due dischi d'oro
vedrebbe oltre 100 immagini
che racconterebbero chi siamo,
la nostra società,
e che descriverebbero
le bellezze del nostro pianeta.
Non solo, perché sentirebbero
i rumori di questo pianeta:
il boato di un temporale,
il fragore della pioggia che cade,
o il rumore di un'eruzione vulcanica.
Sentirebbero i rumori
delle creature della terra,
a partire da quelle che popolano
le profondità delle foreste,
a quelle che camminano nella savana,
fino ad arrivare a noi esseri umani.
Sentirebbero il battito del nostro cuore,
una risata, il pianto di un bambino.
Perché una risata
e il pianto di un bambino?
Perché sono espressioni
universali, e genuine,
delle nostre emozioni,
che non fanno alcuna differenza
di colore o etnia.
Sentirebbero messaggi di pace e saluti
in oltre 50 lingue
dei popoli di questo pianeta.
(Voci in diverse lingue)
E questi siamo noi italiani
che abbiamo affidato il nostro messaggio
ad una ipotetica civiltà aliena.
Ma nei due dischi d'oro,
chiamati anche Golden Records,
sono contenute anche le musiche
che questi popoli hanno prodotto
nel corso dei tempi:
da quelle degli aborigeni,
fino alle meravigliose
composizioni di Beethoven.
Come vedete, all'interno dei dischi d'oro
c'è molto di più di quello
che danno a vedere.
Se una civiltà aliena davvero
fosse in grado di decifrare
il contenuto di questi dischi
scoprirebbe di un mondo unito
nella pace, nella fratellanza,
nell'amore e nel rispetto reciproco.
So cosa pensate: è una menzogna,
a cui nemmeno noi abbiamo
mai creduto realmente!
Però non preoccupatevi,
perché in realtà le Voyager
non si avvicineranno mai nemmeno
a un pianeta abitabile,
non ci sarà mai alcuna civiltà
in grado di raccogliere le sonde
e decifrare quello che è contenuto
nei dischi d'oro.
Ma allora qual è il senso
di averle mandate là nello spazio
con questo carico simbolico?
Perché l'abbiamo fatto?
Perché a ben vedere,
i dischi d'oro contengono un messaggio
che non è davvero per il cosmo:
è un messaggio riferito
a noi stessi esseri umani.
Noi ci estingueremo,
tutto quello che abbiamo mai creato
scomparirà con noi:
la nostra arte, la nostra cultura,
le nostre tradizioni,
la nostra tecnologia,
tutto quello che abbiamo mai prodotto
scomparirà quando l'umanità si estinguerà;
le sonde Voyager continueranno a viaggiare
per miliardi di anni nello spazio
sopravvivendo al nostro tempo,
a noi stessi e anche al pianeta.
Un frammento di noi,
la nostra eredità, i nostri sentimenti,
le nostre emozioni, i nostri pensieri.
Quello che siamo stati o meglio,
quello che in realtà avremmo voluto essere
ma che non siamo mai stati in grado
di mettere in pratica,
continuerà a viaggiare fra le stelle
anche quando noi non ci saremo più.
Noi abbiamo preso il meglio di noi stessi
e lo abbiamo affidato
a queste due navicelle:
quella è la nostra eredità.
È così che noi avremmo voluto essere
e non siamo mai stati
in grado di realizzare.
Le sonde continueranno
a viaggiare per miliardi di anni,
e noi non ci saremo più.
Questo è un piccolo regalo
di un mondo distante
e delle incredibili creature
che lo popolavano,
un segno della loro speranza
e della loro determinazione,
e del disperato bisogno
di sopravvivere al loro tempo
in un universo vasto e fantastico.
(Applausi)